vous avez marre de jouer toujours la
même chose dans l'ouverture vous savez
pas quoi faire sur D4 alors tenter le
très amusant Gambie and clown
caractérisé par ce coup de pion E5 c'est
moins bête que ça en alerte vous allez
avoir les blancs prennent le pion on
sort notre cavalier pour l'attaquer les
blancs font la même chose pour le
défendre dame 7 on attaque le pion n'est
pas que F4 on vient défendre et là on
vient donner un échec qui attaque en
plus le fou qui généralement va donc se
rapatrier en bouclier devant son roi
heureusement j'ai un plan là on va
récupérer notre pion avec les Noirs dame
prend B2 si jamais vous êtes trop a
l'air très tentant pour attaquer la dame
mais c'est là on peut contrer les blancs
avec le très astucieux fou bécartes on
vient clouer ce fou Dame des deux pour
défendre le fou alors fous prends ces
trois c'est la partie osée le paramètre
hasardeux vous voyez si les blancs
reprennent avec le cavalier on gagne
tout simplement une tour et sur dame
prend cette fois c'est la qu'on termine
en beauté par dams et c'est déjà et
Jacquet mat en seulement 8 coups et si
le roi est un cornichon on fait avec